good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight an hour from right now
the vice presidential debate begins in
salt lake city utah it is a legitimate
news event
obviously we're going to be honest with
you under normal circumstances we
wouldn't give it exactly breathless
coverage
it's not that interesting nothing about
the vice presidency is very interesting
quick who did hillary clinton run with
four years ago
if you guessed some guy you're squarely
in the majority of most americans but
don't feel bad about it
history barely records the names of
winning vp candidates
it's fair to say that abraham lincoln
was a pretty big deal he ended slavery
and won the civil war
but how many people remember lincoln's
first vice president hannibal hamlin of
paris hill maine
even in paris hill maine there are some
who've never heard of him
nelson rockefeller became vice president
united states under gerald ford
what do you do all day someone wants to
ask him
i go to funerals rockefeller said i go
to earthquakes
and that was a fair description with the
exception of dick cheney
every modern vice president has been
utterly subordinate to the leader he has
served
most vice presidents are afterthoughts
in this country and that was especially
true
of joe biden barack obama had such a low
opinion of joe biden's intelligence and
his abilities
that he openly mocked him to his staff
twice
obama refused to endorse joe biden for
president presumably for the good of the
country
what's interesting and what's sad in a
way is that years later
joe biden is still in the same role if
he's elected president joe biden would
remain
the junior partner in the white house
biden will be 78 on inauguration day
it's hard to imagine he would finish a
full term but even if he does
kamala harris is more than 20 years
younger she's
sharper more aggressive and far more in
tune with the radical spirit of the
modern democratic party
kamala harris knows what she wants
there's no question she would bulldoze
her elderly sentimental boss
so tonight we'll be airing the vice
presidential debate but we'll actually
be looking at
is kamala harris's audition for the
presidency that's the office she's
running for no matter what they tell you
the debate itself will look weirder than
most of them do
harris and mike pence will be separated
on stage by sheets of plexiglas like the
checkout counter in an inner city liquor
store the biden campaign demanded this
actual scientists laughed at if there's
no measurable health benefit to doing it
but whatever
these are the same people who wear their
masks when they ride their bicycles
they're not interested in what science
says
they want to look serious one thing they
are really serious about though is
ideology they're not kidding kamala
harris has an agenda a real one
over this hour we'll take a close look
at what she would do as our functional
president
those details haven't been much
discussed in the media you may have
noticed
most of the coverage has centered on
questions like how do you say her name
by the way joe biden still doesn't know
he regularly mispronounces it
most of the rest of the coverage of
harris has consisted of warnings that we
had better go
easy on her kamala harris is a woman
any criticism will be regarded as sexist
to be clear not as sexy
but as sexist which is bad watch msnbc
issue the orders today
her team is also aware of the unfair
gendered stereotypes that she might be
up against secretary hillary clinton
advising
senator harris to be assertive to be
firm but also to not do so too strongly
as to be seen as aggressive
unfair to be sure but that's the advice
coming from the first female
nominated to be a presidential candidate
four years ago
oh gender stereotypes what msnbc didn't
bother to explain is how in a world
where we're required to pretend that
gender categories aren't real
how in that world can gender stereotypes
even exist what exactly does that mean
well it doesn't mean anything
obviously it's not a description it's a
threat
leave kamala harris alone or we will
hurt you
we'll smear you as a bigot if you attack
her good luck getting a job after we're
done
harris herself has done this many times
she's a seasoned pro at hiding behind
her own identity
last fall for example polls showed her
losing her home state in the democratic
primary that's
pretty embarrassing but harris had an
explanation for it
californians are racists americans in
general are racist that's why they don't
love me
what i describe and what i believe to be
the elephant in the room about my
campaign what is that
electability what do you mean
electability you know essentially
is america ready for a woman and a woman
of color to be president of the united
states america was ready for
a black man to be president united
states and this conversation happened
for him
there is a lack of ability or difficult
a difficulty in imagining that
someone who we have never seen can do
a job that has been done you know 45
times by someone who is not
that person yeah a lot of racist
democratic primary voters out there
the weird thing is all of these secret
racist democrats voted for barack obama
twice in a row that's pretty strange
behavior for racists
maybe it's harris's indian side they
object to or maybe the whole explanation
is a
ludicrous croc of nonsense that doesn't
even make sense
more likely voters don't like kamala
harris because she is a transparent
fraud
from her phony inflected accent to her
synthetic bio to her featherweight work
history
joe biden's corn pop story is more real
than anything about kamala harris and
it's not even true
democratic pollsters know all this
they've seen the numbers and that's why
they've told harris to start using the
phrase
speaking the truth maybe voters will
think she is
one of the most important values that i
think we must fight for is
is to speak truth to speak truth
we have to speak truth about it we speak
truth
and we are loyal that we speak truth
let's speak
truth let's speak another truth let's
speak truth
we must all speak truth so let's speak
some truth
and we need to speak that truth so we
can deal with it
let's speak another truth let's speak
truth about our economy
and let's speak the biggest truth the
biggest truth of all
let's speak truth yes let's do that